all right welcome to beyond the basics
I'm national master Spencer Feingold and
today we're gonna look at our theme is
going to be centralization when you're
uh when you're you know learning the
basics you learn that you should control
the center especially in the opening
sometimes you know you're playing the
middle game and it's pretty complicated
and you kind of forget that fact maybe
you missed some powerful centralization
moves so we're gonna look at some
examples of powerful centralization in
open and closed positions and we're also
going to look at if you have more space
in the center how to continue then
because you know usually if you have
more control of center you know that's
good but then what all right so first
we'll take a look at a game about four
years ago it was played by yours truly I
had the white pieces and this is the
second round of the Michigan Open I used
to live in Michigan so I'm not going to
go through the opening to too much it
was a slob a sort of mainline my
opponent plays a semi slob and I play
one of the two most common loose III
sort of known as the Moran variation
although after 97 Queen c2 my opponent
played Bishop e7 it's a little bit more
common to see black developing the
Bishop to d6 and why not I mean I can't
pin his Knight
so he doesn't need to go to e7 to break
that pin also I'm not fiing cuddling my
bishop here which would make the bishop
on d6 less powerful you know I'm clearly
gonna get out my bishop more
traditionally on d3 or e2 so Bishop d6
is by far the most common move played by
grandmasters and well anyways Bishop e7
it's a little bit more passive and
against both moves I sort of decided I
was going to play G for this move is
attributed to Shabanov American
Grandmaster of Latvian descent a lot of
Latvian players like to play the move g4
and many different openings not just the
semi Slav they love playing g4 this is
obviously a kind of a weird-looking move
but I'm trying to attack the knight and
gain some control of the center that way
my opponent plays one of the most common
reactions which is to take the pawn it's
free more or less after all also you'll
see grandmasters play D take c4 to give
the Knight to d5 square as another way
of playing and there's other stuff you
could do too but this is a two most
common ways to go so he took and well
when I was talking about what Grand
Master's do usually the bishops on d6
like I was mentioning but rook g1 so I'm
trying to win my pawn back and like I
said don't have to worry too much about
this part of the game but you'll notice
that my opponent he who is Knight many
times in order to trade it so my
opponent he's been sort of moving his
knight a lot and it's neglected his
Queen side development a bit so keeping
in mind the theme of this lecture what
do you think a nice strong move for
white could be
which for be for all right I mean I
guess you want to tack on the queenside
a bit but I'm pretty sure this this
lesson was about the center right yeah
usually you take advantage of your
opponent's lack of development by
attacking in the center they cannot
control the center as well as you I'm
not like why does a huge development
advantage obviously I've been playing
some esoteric moves myself but I can
strike in the center here with a pretty
powerful move
efore alright efore this helps my bishop
on c1 get developed and it gives me a
huge space advantage in the center my
opponent even took my C pawn probably
not the best way to react
I could recapture but I was a little a
little younger than a little more
impetuous so as I don't want to take
that plan I'm just developing I'm all
about the center this game although
probably taking the pawns good my
opponent he was super greedy it's like
I'm keeping that bond yeah I mean I
understand you know you win material
that's pretty good but here white has an
overwhelming presence in the center
well it'll be another powerful central
move here and very often when you when
you're more centralized in your opponent
or if you have better control of the
center even with pawns that will lead to
a big attack well hear my opponent
really can't Castle kingside
so we could we could still attack him in
the center we just got to break open
that Center how do you do it d5 X clam
d5 exactly now my opponents in kind of a
pickle he doesn't really have a good way
of dealing with the tension here in the
center well he did something is very
typical you take once and then push past
this sort of keeps the center closed
more or less but now an extremely
powerful centralization was found by
myself we fix they could solve it really
strong move here
94 is pretty good you're putting a piece
in the center I like that probably he'd
bring his bishop back to e7 right or
even yeah e 7 would be good that's sort
of I want you to play d6 attacking my
Bishop so you can't play Knight d6 and
then I'll just bring my Bishop back to
d8 well it's pretty good move you have a
little stronger though in fact
significantly stronger you'll notice my
opponent has some loose pieces that was
a yellow can be read come on there we go
and that one these pieces are kind of
loose I can touch them both just say
hello you know nothing too serious just
you know a little friendly visit Queeny
for Queen e4 is super-powerful it really
develops the initiative for white I'm
attacking the bishop I'm looking at this
guy in case I play d6 well you know I'm
probably gonna play d6 and if I play d6
the reason I didn't play 94 is I wanted
Knight d5 d6 Knight d5 really
controlling the center very well and
when you control the center I mean you
tell children you're like oh the knight
in the center it can move to eight
squares the side of the bordick only
move to four squares and the corner only
two but really it's important to play in
the center because you can go to all
parts of the board more more quickly
more freely
I hear the Queen in the center of the
board it's eyeing the King hitting the
bishop with the tempo and even on the
Queen's rook as well this Queen controls
a lot of sectors of the board and it's
very powerful move Queenie for us happy
I found it especially because I wasn't
too strong back in this day but my
opponent he saw his Bishop was attacked
d6 he saw I was Rick was attacked and 95
and he brought his Queen all the way
back yeah White has a completely
dominating position here I went on to
win not to not to precisely but you
could see that white really is
dominating the center of the board here
and black is on his back foot I actually
played an unusual move Bishop h6 about
97 check the most obvious which was
probably even stronger
but anyways sort of outside the scope of
this lesson I just wanted to show these
powerful centralization moves
Queenie 4 and 95 but even before that
breaking opened the center with moves
like 'if or and d5 this is how you
punish your opponent for grabbing pawns
moving their knight like five times and
not castling
okay the position the the opening was
very complicated and it's not like that
was the only thing he had to worry about
or myself but yeah a lot of times this
happens you get too caught up on other
things and you forget to get developed
quickly enough all right let's look at
what's next no need to say that all
right so a classic game from 1938 and a
lacking game this is a not elephant's
most famous game probably his game
against ready in Puglia before his two
most famous famous games but this time
he's playing a fellow his name is buck
both of his always should have lots over
them but I didn't know how to do that so
anyways
we get a queen's gambit accepted another
more or less classical opening and it
all has been played many times before
see five castles now here look it wasn't
booked up too well although his name
would suggest otherwise
he played knight c6 it's not a bad move
it looks pretty good and it's 1938 it's
so probably not a lot of games in this
position at that point but nowadays most
grandmasters for plays move a six it's
much more common than knight c6 a little
more flexible to to get a quick b5
Bishop e7 going but yeah like I said
knight c6 not a big problem not a
horrible move really and Queen e2 this
is a way that one could handle if black
did play a six and b5 early in fact he
does go for a six
and b5 so here
well black already made a lot of pawn
moves and didn't develop all his pieces
he had our castle but he makes it yet
another pawn move probably his positions
not bad if he develops one of his
bishops probably what I would do maybe
he didn't want to play Bishop e7 because
he thought white would take on c5 then
and after recapture is he'd be a tempo
slower yeah okay but it's sort of I
don't know what happened in the game
before but White has a powerful reply
here while your Knights attacked how do
you think you would handle this position
with Wyatt
and d5 yeah exactly
pretty similar to that other game
counter-attacking the night as well but
this is pretty difficult for black to
handle well in fact he played Knight a5
attacking the bishop which provoked
I think Bishop a4 check yeah and here
all right what would white do now I
think pretty obvious move white can play
here although some things attacked
already pretty tense position
moving far
ninety-five uh that's pretty sharp but
what if I take your c3 Knight I mean I
have my Bishop defended appropriately
yeah a little bit I do like centralizing
though yeah take on e6 it's the correct
tactical move of course you know he has
to he if he takes the bishop you throw
in he takes f7 swishing hook and get an
extra pawn so he's got to take and ruin
his structure all right but now how do
you continue yeah that's that's what he
did he did Rick do you want now it's
important not to chicken out here and
say oh I have a slightly better pawn
structure I'll just play this position
yeah I probably White's a little bit
better here but I know you deserve more
I would want more rook d1
well this gives up a piece so he took it
so what was triple A's idea Alexander
Alexandrovich a yakin you know you don't
want to mess with a guy like that
Alexander Alexander rich
maybe you wanted to play Rick do you
want to not calculate it but
right I think he took on d7 first and
then 95 right we're okay seven I believe
I'm pretty good at robbing scam it's
like I prepared it and here I can just
recaptures upon and he's playing this
position essentially down a rook and
he's kind of down a piece right because
he can always take on d7 and win the
exchange but he's so well coordinated
and black is quite the opposite his
control and is well centralized Knight
is really putting black under a lot of
pressure and I don't think blacks losing
here I don't even think blacks really
objectively worse mostly because I
analyze this with the chess engine it
said it was equal but during a
tournament game would be very difficult
to play this with black and already
black makes a blunder King e7 well he
was afraid of Queen h5 check
yeah kini 7 it seems haha like how could
that be right right it just seems like
that but if he place up
normal developing move maybe you should
have done this check and takes takes and
just go back reader says equal I'm
pretty sure anything could happen here I
you know it's not really practical to
say this is equal and anything's
possible so even like that it's pretty
good I wouldn't really want to play g6
it seems like a weakening move and I
have a response to g6 but I won't tell
you yet because of how the game went I
don't want to ruin it but alright so
King e7 not the right defense and well
yeah can he's pretty sharp tactically he
noticed hey this is a relationship I'd
like to exploit it but how how could
white do that
yeahi for the idea of Bishop g5 well
sure you could play Knight f6 which he
did immediately and then here but yeah
he's all pinned up whites control of the
center is yeah it's overwhelming already
and yeah he can't get his King side
developed White has a tremendous
compensation here for a whole rook it's
actually winning it's not just
compensation now it's winning he plays
well he wants to get out his dark square
bishop right
I mean I'd want to do that I think oh
well he attacks the knight first oh here
yeah here there's a shocking Queen h5
trying to get in there this is actually
even stronger than what was played I
think maybe he didn't like Queen takes
e5 but it's still Queen yet Chuck time
yeah Queeny a check King d6 false is an
analysis is wrong I'm gonna be
embarrassed Chuck King c7 probably maybe
here this looks like it's about
checkmate time maybe you could even take
the night and made on on d7 but anyways
I wouldn't play Queen a tribe that's
crazy for the record
Bishop i-4 is completely winning and
obvious so that's why he did it
yeah usually you don't want to play the
most complicated way even if the
computer says it's the best you know you
just wanna if you have a simple way and
just go for it
Bishop I for just is really powerful he
has to move his queen again but now
what's the best idea pretty simple idea
here you know Rick do you wanna just get
your last piece into the attack you
don't have to play any fancy move yet
like g4 g5 would be pretty fun idea I
think but yeah get your last piece into
the attack and it's still a ski black
like how do you even move and he can't
move his King because of the rules
there's no legal king move and so he
can't really develop his King side very
easily which is why he played the move
g6 fatally weakening the dark square so
who can find the way to win material by
force you know even though this lecture
is mostly on strategy can't have
strategy without tactics so what's the
winning it's not a combination it's more
like sequence but g6 it is fatally weak
in the dark squares
now we could punish our opponent on the
dark squares if only had a couple more
moves to get his kingside developed be a
pretty easy win for black maybe
what if here
this is correct though yeah
we want to play 97
is that what you're trying to do
I mean if I had white I would try to
probably win this night
97 is crushing he 5 is coming and it 97
prevents for a cafe it as well and so
there's nothing to be done now blacks
gonna lose a ton of material even though
he's upper work he's gonna lose a lot
more well he he did this ran away
probably they're a lot of winning moves
here you don't have to have to worry
about back rank issues because you have
worked d1 Bishop d1 even if you want to
keep your right there so he took it and
play d5 I think it was a resigned time
at this point yeah he looked at his
watch it was shaped like a book and he
resigned Queen f3 is coming next and
black just never got out of the center
powerful centralization at many points
forced book to well keep his pieces on
the side of the board a few key moments
well early before is wrong because the
powerful strike d5 and also obviously
important to throw this in and then a
very nice move rook d1 as suggested by
the audience and this is probably not
completely winning for Wyatt but yeah it
made black it caused a lot of problems
for black and he he faltered here with
King e7 a move that of course looks
wrong but it was just too difficult for
him to find the correct idea also even I
forgot to mention this but even Queen V
it's a fine move here takes takes still
efore like in the game this is just an
unclear position still extra material
for black but a lot of problems to solve
but alright let's let's go on with it to
the next game
what that's the previous game all right
so here's a modern game where
centralization while one side plays the
opening in such a way that he allows his
opponents get a huge center and video
gob with white makes him regret that
decision
perhaps so White's playing in this way
to avoid the Grunfeld defense of course
why it is I'm going to have to be happy
with playing against the Kings Indian
and now he plays a same issue variation
with f3 and black is playing with knight
c6 and a6
this is a common way to play against the
Samish with black also black plays this
way against g3 variations of the King's
Indian and rook b8 a common idea here is
to play b5 kind of the point of a blacks
play and so white is are taking some
measures against that you'll notice that
white is delaying developing his King
side and castling because there the Sun
is pretty closed or at least it would be
become closed it could become closed
after say e5 d5 when the center is
closed you can take a little bit more
time to maneuver around and maybe even
keep your King in the center a bit all
you have to be careful if it opens up
like in the last two games we saw so e6
this looks like kind of a passive move
this position has been played before I
got to say I don't understand this
opening a lot from blacks perspective
probably a king's Indian player would
tell me that it's good or something but
looks like I'd rather have white and
yeah he goes g3 to play Bishop g2 I
remember there was a game recently that
Wang Hao had with black in a similar
position but like I said I don't really
think you know this is the safest way to
play with black let's say so he plays b5
I mean you cannot typically don't want
to let your opponent lord his space
advantage over you without putting at
least some pressure on it he could also
tried to play the move c5 may be
preparing it first with b6 so he doesn't
lose a pawn
but b5 is probably alright and C 5 C 5
is not the only move it it makes sense
so you want to keep the rook on b8 a
little bit more passive and expand in
the center with c5 and he plays before
this is a good move actually it prevents
the Knights from going to c3 among other
things and Knight f2
now black finds a nice way to develop
his Queen side how should black continue
yeah
a-five absolutely followed by Bishop a6
yeah this is uh this is one other good
reason to play b4 it like black did it
opens up this diagonal and the bishop on
a six will be pretty good and whites
bushels not too bad here you know you
wouldn't expect 2650 GM Ganguly to you
know apply too poorly with black
although personally I wouldn't play this
opening but you know that's just me this
is a good way to try to play for a win
with black which is not too easy to do
if your opponent's 2797 and f4 so white
is really really getting a huge space
advantage going and assume the center
locks up with d5 and E 5 well I'm sure
when video golf played off for he was
like well at any point
Ganguly can play d5 and basically force
to e5 but White has a huge space
advantage here and a lot of times that
translates into an attack on the king
and we're gonna see this in not only
this game but also the next game we're
gonna look at when the center is closed
a lot of maneuvering happens but if you
have more space it's a little bit easier
for you and if you have more space in
the center often you can go to your
opponent's king with your pieces more
easily than they can go defend with
their pieces and that's pretty much
exactly what happens
so Knight f5 really important square for
for black here and they prepare it with
King h1 rook e8 this this rule I didn't
understand it computer says it's best
yeah I don't understand it I mean I
guess he's trying to attack on the Queen
side at some points but okay I mean
they're moving around finally he's like
take my Bishop please and f5
well black was worried white would play
off five right
but if 96:5 how do you think you would
handle this with black black actually
has a good way a very easy way to handle
this break without getting a bad
position at all
so black to play how do you defend
against the f5 f5 actually dubious as my
annotation put there yeah it's not easy
I would be thinking this is very good
for white I'd be confident with white
and nervous with black yeah it's
important in a closed position to really
assess these pawn breaks correctly if
you're afraid of a pawn break that
doesn't work you're going to probably
play a bad move based on that judgment
that's exactly what happened here with
Ganguly I mean I think I don't know you
know he's pretty strong so I can't
pretend like I can follow his train of
thought all the time the black does have
a good defense anybody want to give him
one last shot Bueller
right but I think probably f6 is I mean
that variation even better than what
Ganguly did but yeah black should take
once and play bishop c8 this basically
forces white to do something here it
doesn't have anything particularly
powerful for example f6 Bishop f8 I
don't know you just take it right what
am I talking about but you even Bishop
my fate you came to break in this type
of position but you don't usually want
to allow bishop f8 or I mean you don't
want to allow f6 and have to play Bishop
f8 but this is just a non-starter you
can just take it even with yeah just
take it but ok he could take this right
it's the problem here this looks like
one side has two bishops and it's not
white well maybe we should be h3 though
yeah I don't think this is bad for black
his king is relatively safe and not
losing material comfortable I mean
relatively comfortable so f5 was not
killer if I was not a killer break but
yeah like I said when you have this
closed type of position you really have
to judge those pawn breaks accurately if
you think your opponent's pawn break is
stronger than it is you're giving him a
better position than he deserves
especially after f5 he took he could
even have taken on passant which would
have been similar to f6 and EF and
played positionally but I think he had
the idea to swing over to the king
centralized pieces can move more freely
I mean it's gonna be difficult for all
black's pieces to defend the king but
White's ready to bring his Knights in
bring his rook on the G file and see
what's going on you know just going to
the Kings place yeah see how it's
hanging over there
so knight c6 he's well I should get my
knight over to defend and Bishop f3 it's
actually a mistake I mean it's only
moved 25 oh did you have a question Oh
yeah Knight f3 Knight f3 get in there on
g5 rook g1 now even though this only
moved 25 I wouldn't be too surprised
that they're in some time pressure I
noticed in closed positions even though
you know when you look at the game after
it computer says that all the moves are
equal to each other so it doesn't really
matter but you really think like all
these are all these ideas that I have to
be careful about them yeah I mean it's
hard to play without ideas for human and
so we eat up a lot of time in closed
positions so you're gonna move 25 they
could have been pretty low on time in my
experience at least we got Knight f3 is
pretty strong if this should be too you
could play work g1 but work d2 is strong
preparing in the future to double your
works on the G file and why does a big
attack here I don't know if it's
decisive you know I'm not gonna say why
it's gonna win by force with perfect
play here but very comfortable to play
Wyatt one thing to note is opposite
color bishops really favors the attacker
and this is true if he has to play King
h8 and you get your Bishop to g6 it's
difficult for white or for black to
defend on the light squares so Knight f3
would have been good Bishop f3 it's just
not quite as good right now but still
White has a very strong position I mean
he's got a huge space advantage in the
center and he's ready to build up slowly
the attack or it's more difficult for
black to get over and and defend
although he's doing a pretty good job
and here I think he makes kind of a
wrong decision with 98 his idea here as
he wants to play with his rooks on the
second rank on his second rank by
playing c6 and rook a a7 and defending
with his rooks along the second rank
well video golf breaks through that yeah
of course with hindsight it's easy to
say that's a mistake could have played
King AJ it's similar to king h1 like
white played I like getting my King off
the open G file
and with Bishop h6 and yeah I mean
probably white wants to move his white
square bishop now and play Knight f3 and
then Knight to g5 but black can play
rook g7 and he's got some control of the
G file notice if rook g7 you can't take
my bishop cuz where it takes g1 check
when's the Queen you know
rook ji-sun quit JK chicks so you don't
have to worry too much about that
although still why it has all the space
and he's holding the cards pretty much
but after 98 he gets his knight over to
g5 really quickly and gets in here with
Chuck as well already blacks King is
uncomfortable all of White's pieces all
of a sudden are on the Kings side you
know he from when this comes over here
and black he still has got to get some
guys over there
well King h8 defended his Bishop finally
doubled I was waiting for that and takes
takes and he takes this ending the game
I actually Knight f7 wins here 9 f7
check work takes g6 wins not moving wins
because you're threatening all these
things but yeah you just can't play he
can't defend with these pieces he didn't
have enough space to get them over to
the Kings side well like I said he
probably wasn't lost the whole game both
sides made some inaccuracies that we
more or less glossed over because I
guess is beyond the basics not way
beyond the base thanks a little bit
beyond but yeah you could see just
having a big space advantage it's easy
to move all your pieces over your
opponent's king it's a little bit more
difficult for them so let's see one of
my one of my own examples yeah how about
that the only time we have blacks
perspective the game I just play it hot
off the presses you know in the last
month a week or two ago so my opponent
he plays in English and yeah I played
the most aggressive way f5 because my
opponents pretty low rated compared to
me
like 500 points overrated or so
so I really want to win this looks like
a Sicilian Grand Prix attack but with
reverse colors and he plays III now III
is maybe the most common move actually I
used to play this a lot with white I'd
always play e3 in this position thing is
if d3 then I can pin your knight not
that that's a big deal but you know
that's the thing that black can do or if
Knight f3 I'll play Bishop c5 and you
won't play e3 probably because your
Knights on f3 and and can't go to e2 so
that's kind of why people will play the
movie e3 they want to play 92 and you
can't pin my knight I could buy 95 now
haha yeah and I used to think that way
with white and I think III is a good
move III it doesn't develop a piece or
help develop a piece even so it allows
black to play a little bit ambitiously
with the pawn sacrifice d5 something
that i faced with white and I never
really liked facing it with white so I
thought I might as well do with black
then takes and night before I'm just
trying to win the pawn back I'm also
looking at that d3 square wondering what
that's about
looks like check to me
so most people play d3 here including
myself my opponent play d4 a move that I
didn't know and so I went into a deep
think yeah I could take on d4 where he
can't take with the Queen because I for
come on c2 but if he just takes with the
pot and that position is not too good
for me you know I sure I could weed back
my pawn and play this position but don't
you wish my pawn is back here I'll be
way better so yeah I don't need to open
the position up the last thing I need to
do with the pawning with my pawn on f5
so e4x clam my opponent played quickly
here at Bishop f1 as if he had already
had the position but then why would you
play d4 it's not a good move and I know
but and Bishop f1 is like the best move
if he plays Knight h3 I wouldn't just
recapture the pawn
seems like a good idea but after castle
he's gonna play f3 I'm far behind it
developing all of a sudden not really
sure how that happened but next thing
you know you're behind in development f3
is coming and you wish you were showing
more pieces out probably why it's
already better but of course if he
doesn't play Bishop f1 I might as well
give him the check like it's payday King
f1 and just play this position down upon
but with pretty good compensation my
knight is great his King is not great
and I played Bishop d6 so I can answer
Knight f4 by just taking it with my
bishop so I could keep my great Knight
on d3 but yeah probably it's not like
losing for white although computer likes
black usually when you're down upon
computer doesn't like you but instead he
played Bishop f1 probably the best move
I took and he controlled this important
d5 square so my knight on d5 is very
well centralized it can't get kicked
away by the C pawn because he traded
that away he can't get kicked away by
the epochs I played efore this is just
like in a French defense you see this
type of situation happen a lot with
reverse colors again now just like those
out of that other position probably why
it's not worse here it's just really
nice to play with black you can yeah he
stopped b5 didn't really think those
huge priority but you can sort of rest
easy knowing you have good control the
center I mean worst thing that happens
your opponent defense and you can't win
but you know or okay worst thing happens
you blunder and lose right Oh hurts ooh
I mean you know we're playing kind of
normal
my opponent plays b3 well he's defending
his Bishop but what's his secondary
purpose why did he play b3 other than to
protect the c4 bishop
yeah Bishop a3 so what do you think
blacks should do about that can't really
stop it but we can sort of impede it at
least a little bit
this is also a common idea in the French
defense because very often black wants
to trade off his Queens Bishop and hear
my opponent with white who has the
French structure wants to trade off his
Queens Bishop no surprise there and very
often you could play with Chuck
yeah and now just go back
although Bishop d6 would have been
better the point of Bishop d6 is just
immediately take the knight on out for
once it goes there which I was reluctant
to do I want it to like fool around a
little you know see what's going on
first well here my opponents threatening
to take my bishop with his Bishop and 96
Chuck because I can't play Queen tix so
Queen d7 H for stopping g5 and worked
yeah yeah this position it looks very
similar to the previous game with
reverse colors a tribe so my opponent
might be gearing up for Knight g6 not
really right now though I could take it
and play Knight g4 to stop his Queen
from coming in so I don't have to worry
about it right at the second but
definitely something I had to keep my
eye on so yeah you can see I'm really
well centralized I got pretty much all
my pieces right in the center of the
board but the center is closed and not
really easy to make a pawn break is
there I mean so what do you do if you
can't make a pawn break palm breaks are
usually the I mean that's usually how
you plan you know that's that's the next
phase of the game you're gonna break and
then we'll get to that phase and we'll
see what happens hopefully it helped you
but I can't really make a pawn break
right now I have to arrange I guess g5
but that'll take quite a long time won't
it so we just fooled around a bit more a
six a five now you could say I you know
he fixed my pawns
you could also say he put another pawn
on dark square for his Bishop to not
like so I don't know finally I did this
idea Queen f7 you know hurt b1 or c1
rook c8 the reason I played a wreck
cañada is because I wanted to play
Knight g4 and now if he takes on d5 and
I recapture
with the paw and I'm already challenging
the C file again I was mentioning this
last time when you're playing in a
closed position a lot of times you think
that this stuff matters of course it
doesn't computers like every move is
just equal as a matter so that's why I'm
more or less skipping over this part
finally I took the night and here now I
wanted to play rookie six but the astute
audience member will notice four key six
as a tactical flaw
what would be wrong if I played rookie
six
right yeah so the C pawn would be pinned
Bishop takes d5 wins a rook actually or
more so I have to my right back
yeah there okay so you finally got his
Bishop working right this is probably
this is the the downside to be playing
Bishop takes Knight on a f4 but still as
bishop it's not too close to his King I
have more I have a big space advantage
and so I'm sort of trying to go over to
the King now just like in that last game
I didn't know that last game while I was
playing this game but you know it seems
like pretty obvious idea again I have to
play g5 it's the only pawn break I have
I have to arrange it at least cam really
don't really want to play right now I
guess but well now I can play Rickey 6
like was my plan rook h4
oh he's preparing to defend this she did
now I play Queen f6 this move has my
point is I want to play g5 still but I'm
preventing him from taking on passant
because this work would be hanging on h4
so that's why he played somewhat
shocking move and it reminds me of that
alley akin book game not that you guys
remember it but King g3 he moves his
king up again probably not correct I
mean just like book did yeah it makes
sense though he's protecting his rook on
h4 so if g5 he can take on Poisson and
his work isn't hanging on h4 he could
have played a more normal move it's like
Bishop c5 and doesn't really do anything
but just like all of our other moves
sort of and yeah I could still play with
g5 or arrange it more but now okay still
he can't take on a ton g6 on passant
because this work would be hanging but
he can just play this position it's not
bad I mean what's the problem I have no
threat really sure I could play King h8
and rook g8 and get some play going but
I still have a lot of work to do if I'm
trying to win this game with black
instead of Bishop c5 he plays King g3
right and I still play King h8 this is
just like that other game Wow
it's like I prepared a good lecture
unbelievable sort of by accident but no
I I knew there was some way and he takes
again yeah I don't know why he relieved
tension here finally I mean he could
have taken this fish of a hundred times
and I'm not gonna take his bishop on c4
I mean what he took he played Queen c4
that's crazy I mean don't you think your
king is gonna be a little vulnerable it
was just begging for g5 I obliged him
and yeah now it's actually completely
winning he took on passant taking even
taking with the rook is good hanging h7
with check yeah that's just completely
winning but queen takes is also good
took the rook Knight takes discovered
Chuck King h3 alright so who could find
a good plan of attack I'll tell you
right now black is completely winning I
mean White's King is just too out of
control over there just completely out
of control
and his piece is on the Queen side yeah
this is a symptom of having less space
in the center your pieces have a
difficult time going over to the other
side of the board although he
purposefully played Queen C for us right
no I mean I was sitting here at this
point I had like 15 minutes my opponent
had one minute and I was sitting here I
couldn't find a way to beat my opponent
by force you know looks so good but you
cannot like mate he can defend with
Queen f1 and a lot of variations I
played rook da that's a winning move but
he can defend I mean Bishop e7 he's
actually losing here so how do you
finish him off
I hear i blundered it because I thought
for like 11 minutes on my previous move
I had not a lot of time right I did
check on H on H five and and that
actually doesn't win well let's say we
continue he'll block it up will you just
play Knight f7 that's pretty much it he
can't do anything after this you know
rook G one Queen h5 check followed by
Knight take g5 well in the game just
straight up at in the game so this is
this would have been the ticket home
pretty much the last thing I'd have to
find but instead I wrong next I check
check
I mean I did all this good-looking stuff
but now what okay Knight g4 you might
think right I didn't do this I was
afraid of rook takes h7 it actually
doesn't work because that's why I put
double question mark takes check you got
two legal moves
what does black do here see now I don't
feel so bad about thinking rook g7 will
draw I'll play Queen h5 check what King
h8 wins yeah the night control Z square
is it's important yeah I didn't want to
do this because I had like a second left
on my lot but yeah here it's winning
four black just nothing do so Knight g4
work takes h7 doesn't work but he can
just defend and I still can't win riot
in fact I have to do like this and I
didn't have to sacrifice the rook there
but you know I could and draw so Knight
g4 didn't work not for the reason I
thought but hey what he gonna do so
instead I checked we were peated a lot
and yeah I worked g6 so I could have
repeated and drew that would have won me
the tournament but I'm too high rated I
couldn't do it I just have to I mean my
opponents 500 points lower rated me we
both have like 6 seconds left this is a
super complicated position if you're not
gonna win that when are you gonna win
all right I mean if you're not gonna win
this type of position where g6 is
actually a bad move because he could
just take it and I would have to give
perpetual here you might think well why
don't you go and win the bishop right
because of Queen f7 powerful move and
now White's winning yeah I got nothing
going on here I still would have done
this cuz I never would draw him but he
didn't probably didn't see work takes h6
because again we both had just second
left
so he goes threatening nothing it's
starting check I guess yeah here so
doesn't have a real threat but anyways
so I do this again you notice the strong
players they always repeat you know even
though I'm not that strong I'm still
strong enough to repeat and then King g8
now 94 now wins
well right I thought this would be
winning for winning for him or drawing
for him but this is check yeah well I
had 5 seconds left come on what you want
see how Knight g4 does win because I can
take back with check there in that
variation but King g8 Queen e7 actually
not a bad move yeah you know I did this
yeah my opponent he didn't like that I
was repeating so much but it's a good
idea to repeat it it hurts your opponent
psychologically of course my opponent
wants to draw here I mean he was like
losing the whole game pretty much well
at least you know when I started opening
up a bit but yeah don't draw never draw
yeah I just picked the first move I
could find which didn't lose or draw
instantly so he did take so I knew my
opponent had seen this before even
though it didn't work before because he
did it now now if I took his if I took
his rook
he can't perpetual but you could just go
here I can't win this this is impossible
to win I mean what could I do I'm gonna
win with just my queen
probably not am I gonna get my rook in
there I don't really see how if I do
he's gonna check make me a perpetual
check me with his Queen and Bishop this
position is so drawn even the computer
says it's a draw and usually computer
likes rook more than bishop but that's
the date day and age we live in so again
with just like one second left
each pretty much we had delay but the
five seconds goes by faster than you dot
you'd want so this move I wasn't sure if
I was losing now after this because it
looks like I'm getting mated my opponent
he made a horrible blunder again just
the tension of the situation was too
much for him to bear Queen e8 check yeah
yeah and I took this finally my contempt
paid off yeah just not agreeing to a
draw was what won me this game I mean
it's really difficult to play with just
one second left every move for like 10
15 moves and then he fin to this and
yeah made it so I hope you guys learned
a lot about the importance of the center
at least more than a basic lesson would
be so try to control that Center and
make those powerful centralisation moves